a lot of people are nervous about where
the economy is headed and many are
wondering what it will mean for the las
vegas housing market which has been
scorching hot for the last couple of
years joining us to discuss that is
radio host and realtor harvey blankfield
along with john ingram thank you both
for being here gentlemen thanks for
having us kendall let me introduce john
john's with prosperity homework he's the
branch manager and he's a lender that we
do a lot of business with and uh he
brings a lot of knowledge uh so that's
and he's on the show our radio show
regularly and he brings that knowledge
if they want to hear more from john
after today tune into the radio show
tell people when they can catch up
saturday mornings at 11 a.m on kdwn uh
every saturday las vegas real estate now
when we talk about all things real
estate that's where on the dial
101.5 fm 7 20 am well let's talk about
these the home prices have been going up
and up but it seems like they're
leveling off a bit at this point yeah
with this the appreciation rate is
slowing down quite a bit and uh
the inventory has been increasing we've
seen it go up uh it was 2 000 a little
over 2 000 homes at the beginning of the
year it's about 4 000 homes around the
beginning of this month there's over
5000 single-family homes available right
now so it's been creeping up it's not at
a balanced market yet but it's getting
there it's getting it's still so still
seller side it's not a buyer's market
yet but it's getting a little easier on
buyers do interest rates have anything
to do with that well let's ask john
about that i mean i think so john just
recently the federal government uh
raised interest rates by i believe it
was three quarters of a point correct
how does that affect housing well it's
really interesting because a lot of
people would make the assumption that
that increase would directly move
interest rates up on mortgages and in
fact the opposite happened we saw
interest rates decline after they
increased the fed funds rate by that
three-quarters
so things actually got a little better
this week not always the case though
right sometimes there is a relationship
absolutely typically there would be the
fed moving that rate up would pressure
mortgage rates up but in this particular
moment in time
mortgages are more heavily reacting to
what's going on with inflation
and when the fed signals that um that
they're getting serious about reacting
against inflation mortgages took that as
a real positive sign that that they can
get this heading in the right direction
and they improved because of that it is
interesting to think about with
inflation going the way it is is
inflation going to eat away at some of
the uh equity that people have built up
as a result of the housing prices going
up well you know it's it's a great
question that for economists i would
have to i'd defer to them but i would
say this is that right now the way we're
seeing things and everything i hear is
houses are going to continue to
appreciate and even if we get into a
recession kendall i'm going to say that
housing should still do very very well
unlike the last recession which was
caused by housing yeah every other
recession we've had in the last five or
six housing is not only held on it's
actually held its own it's actually done
a little bit better my understanding is
that the bubble that existed in 2000
late 2008 seven whatever it was right
was largely in part that people were
over leveraged in this case a lot of
homes have a lot of cash in them now
absolutely you know it's a completely
different uh dynamic right now where you
got back then people could borrow money
just by signing a piece of paper yeah
now now john's cup that no lender will
let anybody borrow a home unless they
can actually afford it
they really vet the buyers very
carefully now which protects everybody
in the lab it protects our market it
really does they've done a wonderful job
so anybody's bought a home in the last
20 years knows the mortgage companies
are looking deep deep deep into your
financial history and you've got to also
keep in mind there that for the last 15
years or so 80 plus percent of all
transactions were owner-occupied unlike
what we had previously where everybody
in the world was an investor in the las
vegas market yeah yeah all right good to
hear the optimistic outlook appreciate
you both gentlemen thank you very much
for being here and we want to thank las
vegas real estate for sponsoring this
segment for more information you can
visit
lvrealestateradio.com or call that phone
number 702-203-1165